Transcriptor: Jhosua Vera
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Tenemos miedo a la grandeza de lo posible.
Tenemos miedo a que nos digan que no,
tenemos miedo al fracaso
y que no salgan las cosas
como nosotros queremos.
El miedo es algo que traemos dentro.
Siempre estamos conviviendo con él ¿no?
Pero tenemos que aprender
que si hay miedo, hay obscuridad.
Pero donde hay oscuridad, hay luz.
Y donde hay miedo, hay valentía.
Cuando el miedo se apodera de nosotros,
nos paraliza.
Como ahorita ¿no? (Risas)
pero si lo permites,
nunca vas a saber lo grande que eres
y las grandes obras que puedes crear.
Hola, soy Sergio Calderón.
Soy padre de dos niños.
Empresario, esposo, tengo 38 años
construyendo mis sueños
y transformando la energía.
¿Por qué transformando la energía?
Porque eso es a lo que me dedico
profesionalmente, a lo eléctrico.
Pero también la transformo porque todos
los días hay energía positiva y negativa
en mí.
Mas sin embargo, esa la canalizo
para poder llegar a mis objetivos.
Me he convertido en un hombre
que escribe su propia historia.
Desde pequeño he aprendido a superar
mis barreras y limitaciones.
Uno de los primeros retos
que tuve fue en primaria.
Yo tenía problemas de lenguaje,
no me podía expresar con otros amigos
o la maestra no me podía entender.
Pero gracias a la constancia y
perseverancia y apoyo de mi madre,
pude superar este reto.
Me di cuenta de que la constancia jugaba
un papel muy importante en todo esto.
Atravesar este desafío
abrió un nuevo mundo en mí.
Me volví más curioso.
Lo que me ayudó a conocer una de mis
pasiones, la historia y la geografía.
Me cuestionaba sobre nuestro pasado,
sobre nuestros orígenes.
Pero también descubrí personas que,
gracias a su visión y a su perseverancia,
lograron un mejor mundo en
donde vivían y en donde vivimos.
También comprendí que la perseverancia
siempre lleva a grandes logros,
pero también hay momentos difíciles
para llegar a ellos.
Hablando de grandes retos
y obstáculos por vencer,
otro momento que marcó mi vida
fue el divorcio de mis padres.
Hubiera sido fácil para mí culpar a ello
de todos, mas sin embargo,
cambié la narrativa.
Le agradecí por todo lo que
me dieron y lo que tuve.
Y gracias a eso busqué
mi tierra prometida.
¿Cuál es? El tener una familia amorosa.
Cuidar de ella, estar al pendiente
de ella, tener un trabajo,
desarrollarte como persona,
encontrar mi libertad.
Y una de las cosas más importantes
que he aprendido en los últimos años,
equilibrar el trabajo
y el tiempo con la familia.
La familia es algo
muy importante para mí.
Con ella comparto mis triunfos
y también mis derrotas.
Al final del día quiero verlos a ellos,
porque ellos hacen que todo valga la pena.
Es por eso lo importante que es equilibrar
entre la familia y el trabajo,
para que puedas compartir
lo que haces y lo que ganas.
Busquemos siempre los tiempos para uno,
para con tus hijos, para con tu esposa,
para darnos y darles
la mejor de las experiencias.
La búsqueda de algo mejor
despertó en mí la curiosidad
para desarrollarme como mejor persona.
La curiosidad hizo encontrarme
con los Scouts.
Con los Scouts realicé varias actividades
al aire libre, lo que empezó
como una curiosidad a través
de escuchar y descubrir.
Encontré nuevas habilidades
con la constancia y la pasión
para poder superar retos.
Puedes ser un gran líder y tener personas
a tu cargo, las cuales puedes apoyar
mientras tú logras también tus objetivos
y con esto puedes ser
un verdadero agente de cambio en el mundo.
En los scouts hay un concepto que siempre
me ha gustado que es rema tu propia canoa.
¿Qué significa?
Que hagas tu propio camino.
Que en el remar,
te vas a encontrar a veces
con la corriente del río
y a veces contracorriente.
Pero lo importante es siempre
siendo tú y nadie más.
Empecé a remar con más
fuerzas y más ganas.
Soy parte de una familia que
se ha dedicado al giro eléctrico
toda la vida.
Por lo tanto, hay una tradición
que los miembros de la familia
se tienen que dedicar a eso.
Desde niño me inculcaron esta gran
tradición y los caminos recorridos
por el abuelo, el papá y los tíos.
Con este tipo de situaciones
uno se puede perder en el camino
y también perder de vista el objetivo,
porque te puedes adueñar de una idea ajena
y perder tu individualidad.
Pero ¿saben?
Esto se trata de ir hacia
la tierra prometida.
El remar contracorriente y ser parte
de un grupo de personas.
En este caso, mi familia, en donde
tú piensas que hay que cumplir
y hay que hacer lo que el papá hace
o lo que el abuelo hizo.
A pesar de este tipo de situaciones,
siempre tienes que tener muy claro
hacia dónde vas.
Siempre ser tú y evitarte
perder en el camino.
Si lo haces, estar atento para poderlo
encontrar nuevamente,
no renegar de lo que hay,
porque al final de cuentas,
por lo que hay eres la persona
que eres el día de hoy.
Entonces, ¿qué hacer?
Bueno, aprovechar lo que hay
para poder usarlo como trampolín
y llegar a donde tú quieres en la vida.
Eso fue lo que pasó.
Yo estudié ingeniería electromecánica
y empecé a trabajar con mi papá.
Gracias, en cierta forma,
a la libertad que él me dio
pude desarrollar varios proyectos dentro
de la empresa con los cuales descubrí
y desarrollé habilidades
que desconocía, que tenía.
También la constancia y la disciplina,
una vez más me llevaron a realizar cambios
en la esencia de la empresa
los cuales me sirvieron
para sentar las bases
de lo que yo traía en mente
para el futuro.
A pesar de todo esto,
fueron tiempos difíciles
porque como ya habíamos
dicho anteriormente,
nos preocupamos en pensar
lo que la gente espera de nosotros.
Y la búsqueda personal
está en lo que tú quieres.
En la búsqueda de lo que yo quería,
me di cuenta de nuevos servicios
y tecnologías
que se estaban dando en el área eléctrica,
los cuales me llamaban la atención
y decidí ofrecerlos y desarrollarlos.
Recibí comentarios muy negativos
de mi familia.
Me dijeron eso no va a funcionar,
¿para qué lo intentas?
Pero, ¿saben algo?
Los ignoré y seguí remando.
Así fue como empezó mi empresa.
Un día 10 de marzo de 2008
con una primera venta de 700 pesos
me sentí el hombre más rico del mundo,
le hablé a mi novia, ahora mi esposa,
y le dije nunca se te olvides de este día,
porque a partir de hoy
el mundo va a cambiar.
Y así fue.
También estudié una maestría
en administración.
Estudiar esto me ayudó a darme cuenta
de otro mundo lleno de posibilidades
y cómo adaptarlas a lo que hago
o en lo que puedo hacer.
Una de ellas son las estrategias
de vender lo que haces.
Eso captó mi atención y curiosidad
para siempre.
En el camino del crecimiento de mi empresa
me di cuenta de que
no siempre vas a estar motivado,
sino que hay que ser disciplinado.
Con esto en mente,
logré acreditar el primer laboratorio de
pruebas de transformadores en Tijuana
y mi empresa es una de las empresas
que ofrecen los servicios especializados
y productos de una manera
puntual y dinámica.
También, a pesar de las adversidades del
año pasado y todo lo complejo que fue,
abrimos un nuevo negocio
donde vendemos hamburguesas.
En este lugar ofrecemos
un menú simple y sencillo.
¿Por qué unas hamburguesas?
Porque evoca para mí la infancia.
Una infancia en donde pues lo único que
había que hacer aquí en Tijuana era cruzar
al otro lado y comerse una hamburguesa
en San Isidro.
Para mí era el top de la semana ¿no?
que nuestra madre nos llevaba.
Y esa misma experiencia,
pues la quiero llevar a las
personas que visitan el lugar.
Si todo sale bien, vamos a abrir
otra nueva sucursal este año.
Al final se trata de
conectarte contigo mismo
para que sepas qué es lo que
quieres y cómo lo quieres,
porque las demás personas
pueden decir y hablar,
pero a final de cuentas,
tú lo vas a hacer.
Así que siempre hay que ser
honesto y auténtico.
La lucha es de diario.
Hay una frase que siempre retumba en mí
todos los días o parte de la semana,
que es no está en el genio,
sino en la perseverancia
lo que a un hombre
lo hace llegar a la cima.
Y tú ¿cuando empiezas ese camino?
Gracias.